hey i'm mike ettineau uh character
animator on the simpsons hey
i'm kira lead animator on good advice
cupcake today we are drawing
justice league characters from memory
from memory
wow justice league yeah i think i love
them
do you know who the justice league are
you sound very confident
[Music]
all right give us the characters matt
today is drawing plaid
the flash was my favorite one seriously
wow
your character today is wonder woman
i feel like that's manageable i'll try a
picture in my head superman
okay it's like the worst one i would who
is your favorite justice league
character uh
probably batman batman is too angsty
and superman is too serious and he's a
real
but the flash is just right i like
bumbling buff idiots
you really do yeah i like the dumb ones
that's your type i had no idea that you
were a flash fan
i really thought that you were going to
be like what what do you know about the
flash huh
i know that his superpower is super
speed
i know that his name is barry allen yeah
superman is a man that is super
very powerful laser eyes x-ray vision
there is nothing that he can't
do i know vague generalities about dc
characters but i don't
you know i don't know much i remember i
read one of the flash comics and i was
surprised to learn he doesn't
only go fast but he also can learn fast
that's cool i guess isn't that wild and
wacky stop saying while we're wacky
isn't that wild and wacky with barry
allen
and turned off my cintiq turned off your
cintiq how do i turn it back on
superheroes are hard to draw so what do
you usually start with when you draw
i'll usually try to start with the line
of action which kind of acts as like the
character
spine for the pose it's like a guideline
for how the pose will lay
mine's different every single time yeah
i'll start with the body
one day i'll start with the head one day
i even started with a hand one time
that's a good choice i love drawing
hands people are such a weak
they're always like i hate drawing hands
shut up they're
fun the buttons up here yeah it's up
here it's over here on your side
what did i do i always draw like 16
fingers on one hand people are like
did you notice did you notice there's 16
fingers on the hand instead of five i'm
like why would i draw 16 fingers on
accident
are you crazy i like how they ask you
that question as if you're like close
your eyes
and do hands like whoops fix it fix it
fix it listen
fix it fix it fix it fix it fix it fix
it fix it fix it fix it check it fix it
oh i fixed it that was cool it's a good
thing i was i
thought quick on the fly like flash what
you know what i don't like this i don't
like what i'm drawing you're restarting
i'm restarting i'm going to draw a cute
flash
i'm sorry this is just how it has to be
i got the pose
now i just got to do the details and i
don't know the details of his suit
i know that you know you can't really
see his eyes right right he's got kind
of a batman mask yeah batman mask
he has he has the thing where his eye
mask moves with his emotions right
which is weird that doesn't happen in
real life no her style of dress is kind
of i think it's like
sort of like a gladiator kind of yeah a
little bit
i know he's got tiny squinty tiny tiny
tiny eyes
big angular jaw curly hair i just know
that it's red
yeah but there's nothing else in my head
right now yeah i know that he has the
you know headphone things
i got that yeah does he have a belt like
a
waistband maybe oh man what are her
shoes she isn't
she doesn't have a shield does he i
don't think so she has like her
her gauntlets right right on a rope in
the robe
i did watch the live action 90s flash
show
oh how did that work out it was actually
that bad for the first season
and then it got terrible okay but that
flash
for some reason i know that he has a
belt
with the flash symbol on it was it a
rope called again
the lasso of truth does he have a
flash like a lightning symbol on his i
think so
on his chest i think he does because
they sell flash shirts
oh right
how are you doing joanie i am having
a hard time however i like what's
happening to mine
yeah it's not that great but it's like
there should be low expectations for me
is all i'm saying
everyone's a critic everyone's a credit
do you have a favorite
comic book hero movie really like
deadpool deadpool
yeah i feel like maybe the reason why i
hate superman and like batman and all
these people is because like i
would be one of the villains like i feel
like i really like fit into that
category
and how i act generally villains are
anti-establishment
true yeah and i'm always like tweeting
about how i hate amazon
yeah it's the same it is the joker
burning things down and me tweeting
about how i hate amazon are like the
same thing
that's disconcerting okay i gave him way
too much crotch
how you doing over there i think i'm
doing okay
uh i'm tr struggling to remember this
costume
i honestly don't remember anything about
the costume i'm kind of winging it and i
think there's a w on her tiara
yeah you're right i feel like she has a
sword too i have no idea what that looks
like though
all right my flash is looking cute
there's a lot of flashes so
who can really say this is accurate too
my drawing kind of looks like if a super
villain was trying to draw
superman like trying to make fun of him
kind of
i think i'm just i think i'm just
straight up a villain from
dc but i love this idea of method
drawing you embody the character
i decided not to commit to color so i'm
just gonna add like tones
sometimes color just like makes or
breaks it
yeah are the colors switched maybe
they're switched you know
i don't really know what his symbols
colors are uh
but i'm gonna go with white and yellow
yeah it seems seems correct
he's kind of looking more like a
mcdonald's character right now than uh
than a justice league character i
apologize to barry allen and his son
wally west oh wait is his son
no i don't think so all right i think
i'm done here i think i'm done
okay okay i drew a handsome man
because apparently even if you're from
space you you're just handsome
[Music]
okay now i need to do like a speed
effect real quick
here's what i'm going to do i'm done i'm
going to take the whole thing
i'm going to pretend like i'm driving
located i'm going to do
a directional blur hey remember the
thing you can do to make it look like
your pencil is wobbly
we get it jackie you finished before i
did i'm trying to entertain them
done you done kevin done with my flash
finished it in a flash
so mike how do you think you did i
wasn't sure about
her costume i don't know if it's a
two-piece if it's a one-piece
how about you i feel like i i remembered
some of the stuff about like the central
costume but uh colors it looks like a
halloween store like discount cost
hey june how'd you do i did okay i i
superman
um in transition from the mild-mannered
man
becoming superman mine is very plain
i am going to warn you though there's a
lot of crotch coming your way again
bringing up the crotch there's a lot of
crotch coming away so you're just going
to have to deal with it i'm just going
to deal with flash's groin
his costume is so simple that there's no
way to mask his groin
i mean there is but you know kevin i'm
just going to let it slide this time
because i don't want to hear you say
crotch again i'm just letting you know a
lot of crotch
all right let's switch oh wow
this looks so good oh my gosh you made
it look incredible
you actually added full color this looks
like a finished awesome drawing yours
looks like i love the style
yours has such a great pose like it's
like that fibonacci spiral around
it's like pleasing to look at yes
this is yes i love the superman
you dream so cute you do i love it
i think that like you just like kind of
drew him you know
you really overplayed the crotch the way
you
described it i was thinking you gave him
like a basketball
in there it's really not that bad very
spiky lightning bolt
yeah yeah i think i put too many spikes
on it i think it's going the wrong way i
think you got it the right way
i don't i you never know oh oh yeah you
got it oh
she's just wearing like a bathing suit i
guess i was remembering the movie
too much yeah i don't know why but for
some reason we thought she had a w on
her two
i forgot the stars yeah the stars she's
really really patriotic
i completely forgot more patriotic than
i thought there he is yeah you literally
just drew him like when i said that
earlier like i meant it it was like
he literally just did it joni captured
the inner essence of superman because
there's a cost of being super at all
at all times does it cost what wow
no no no this isn't the flash i know
wow he's got full on yellow boots
which yeah neither of us you know what
it's not fair
to judge our flash off of one flash
drawing because there's so many
variations there's many classes so many
costume changes he goes through this is
true
maybe this is casual day flash it's hard
to get those little details
but the broad idea i think i think we i
think we got it
got close enough close enough flash is a
cool guy flash is a cool guy he's a
chill guy
uh cool super power i wish i was fast
so do i yeah i'm real slow i'm real slow
when it comes to drawing
i'm real slow when it comes to thinking
am i right ladies two brain cells
hands up that's millennial talk for you
what does that mean
[Music]
you